[Music]
welcome to the Avenger
she's a repurposed alien transport ship
should make for the perfect mobile HQ
to finish that is from here we can
strike against alien positions across
the globe
she's not without her clerks though if
you listen to Shen the ship has a mind
of its own and I don't mean the AI we've
been reclaiming it piece by piece but
we've still got plenty of work ahead of
us so far we've managed to outfit her
with everything we thought you'd need to
get started along with some new
additions I think you'll approve of
which reminds me
you better head down to the lab you'll
want to meet dr. tigon there's a few
things you two should discuss impressive
is it capable of generating immense
power
you're completely harmless to human life
if only the same could be said for the
rest of the aliens technology commander
dr. Richard Tigan chief science officer
I am responsible for the entirety of our
research here as well as the procedure
you've so recently underwent welcome to
my lab such as it is I'm not sure what
central may have told you but we found
something while removing you from the
alien stasis suit a device implanted
directly in your occipital lobe and I
access to the equipment available to me
during my tenure at Advent I would
already know the precise nature of its
function
however given time and your
of course commander I assure you I will
find out which brings to light an
additional point though aspects of this
facility are indeed impressive I am but
one man were you to direct additional
support personnel and resources to me I
could substantially improve the speed of
all our research affair well commander
Diegans one of the best minds on the
planet
Vladdy saw the light came over to the
right side still he's not kidding about
needing that support with advent
controlling most of the world it's not
just resources that are scarce but
manpower too
we're running a skeleton crew right now
commander it'll be up to you to decide
how to assign the staff we do have
genetic research has come a long way
since you've been gone given time and
effort there's no telling what kind of
enhancements we'll be able to provide
our soldiers
smart move they should be able to patch
up our troops more efficiently and get
them back into the fight even faster as
smart as he is
tige ins research can only go so far
without a solid engineering team to back
him up you better check in on shin okay
reworked your repulsors with some of the
Parts I salvaged from your old agent
should fix that stabilization problem
you have come on Rover it'll work
commander getting our tech to talk to
theirs is harder than you think
Lily Shen chief engineer at your service
you are probably expecting to see my
father and all that's happened
I'm guessing central didn't tell you yet
he's gone dad gave everything he had to
get us this far this entire ship is his
life's work
I know he would have loved to show you
around the place himself he used to talk
about you a lot you can be sure I'm
ready to finish what he started
might not look it but I'm here I can
fabricate pretty much anything to come
up with and with a little more help well
you'd be amazed with what I can do it
was an honor to finally meet you
commander wouldn't even be this far
along if it weren't for her with your
support I know she'll make her father
proud
proving grounds Shen's name and not far
off with resources being so scarce these
days sir people have had to get creative
with their designs ammo explosives armor
the end result isn't always predictable
but so far it's been damn effective nice
if you're really itching to give that
ammo a try assign an extra engineer to
work on the project
call that will cut down our
manufacturing time significantly
research and manufacturing are a key
part of the process but at the end of
the day it takes soldiers to win a war
picked up a few tricks over the years
put them to use here advents got us
outgunned and outnumbered so we had to
adapt specialized our training and
tactics to target their weaknesses and
play up our strengths
Rangers operate in the shadows they like
to handle things up close and personal
it's gonna take everyone we've got to
win this war our soldiers performed
admirably in the OP to get you back to
Mecca we should check in on them at the
armed
when we first deployed these gremlins we
had no idea how effective they'd be in
combat and our specialists continued to
take them to new levels we can configure
the drones to provide remote medical
triage or tailor them to dish out some
serious punishment to the enemy can't go
wrong either way commander
gone are the days when we had a flood of
new recruits coming in from nations
around the world it's on us now to build
an effective fighting force out of
what's left of humanity
all walks of life these days civilians
combat vets and everyone in between
can't say I never imagined seeing some
of these recruits and an ex-con
uniformed back in the day still they've
got the guts to go up against that vent
and that's enough for me well adding
some big guns that part we do have
covered the last human run manufacturing
plant shut down about 20 years ago which
makes getting hold of replacement parts
tougher every day so we improvised take
what we can from the enemy and turn it
right back against them
[Music]
works for me
well commander now that you've got a
handle on the tools at your disposal we
should discuss how to put them to use
it's on a secure Channel patching it
through to your quarters now
hello commander it is good to see you
again we need you to take charge of
resistance operations throughout the
world establish contact with the local
cells and bring them into the fold save
our world
time is short commander good luck so
much for easing into things we better
get started
the aliens may have the world in their
grip but a small number of us are trying
to change that right now we're in
scattered pockets we need to get
organized
tige ins work is the first step in that
process
good we just went live
already getting a read on a few regions
we can't be everywhere at once commander
we need to choose our moves carefully
help our allies while disrupting enemy
operations to build the resistance
on route
it's gonna take time to get actionable
Intel on the area
our operatives need to make contact with
the locals get the lowdown on the
looks like Shen's people came through
looking forward to putting these to use
there's word of a supply depot not too
far from our position we can head there
now or try establishing contact with
another region good call commander we'll
need every resource we can get if we're
going to take the aliens down
[Music]
[Music]
we can travel to a new region or
continue to investigate activity here
say the word commander and we'll make
contact
getting intel on some enemy blackops
projects this is the stuff that doesn't
make the headlines they never end well
we won't have time to strike them all so
we need to choose which project we
target carefully multiple hits on the
resistance comms commander raids like
these are our best bet at uncovering
what advents really up to got a lot of
activity on the board right now so just
give the word we're on it